bonjour gérard chaliand vous êtes
géostratège spécialiste des conflits
armés irréguliers votre dernier ouvrage
le savoir de la peau aux éditions de
l'archipel merci d'être avec nous tout
d'abord comment analysez vous
l'évolution de la situation actuelle pas
d'une façon générale les russes sont
toujours sur l'offensive
il n'y a pas eu de contre offensive
sérieuse du côté des ukrainiens parce
qu'il semble qu'il n'en ai pas les
moyens
l'avancé et russe en définitive se
projette sur la partie orientale du pays
du nord au sud
c'est en sommes à peu près un quart de
la partie orientale du pays qui est tenu
par les russes
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent
d'une part neutraliser un certain nombre
de villes
personnes
peut-être kharkiv et de façon ultime
évidemment serrer au maximum
autour de kif et si possible
se débarrasser de l'appareil d'état de
l'adversaire c'est à dire de monsieur et
risque jusque là c'est clair après point
d'interrogation on ne sait pas
exactement où on va l'effondrement de
l'urss avait signé la fin de la guerre
froide et personne ne pensait que la
guerre pourrait revenir un jour en
europe est ce que vous vous êtes surpris
très honnêtement oui je suis surpris
quand même dans la mesure où je pensais
que pendant longtemps monsieur
poutine se contenterait de gesticuler de
menacer mais pas d'entrer véritablement
dans un conflit où il joue petit ou
double alors maintenant que c'est fait
dire que ses chances sont total ce
seraient s'avancer c'est à dire que on
ignore finalement le dénouement de cette
affaire
les occidentaux d'une façon générale ont
abattu leurs cartes c'est à dire que
nous n'interviendrons pas militairement
mais les mesures de rétorsion les
sanctions sont extrêmement sévères
évidemment pour que des sanctions
comment dirais-je fasse sentir leurs
effets il faut du temps alors ce temps
monsieur poutine doit l'utiliser le plus
rapidement possible essayer de conclure
sans s'enliser
c'est son problème c'est le pari tout
paris de la situation et là les
exigences de la dit mi-août in pour
revenir un peu en arrière vis-à-vis de
l'otan est ce que ce sont selon vous des
prétextes pour justifier des agressions
ou est ce une réalité
écoutez on il faut il faut voir le point
de vue de monsieur poutine 1 je veux
dire dans cette affaire là vous pouvez
vous indiquer hier disant bon il ya
beaucoup de victimes
il ya un gentil et un méchant non moi je
ne crois pas ce genre de choses l'état
des lieux c'est que du côté de monsieur
poutine son sentiment
parfaitement justifiée
c'est que au lendemain de l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique
indiscutablement les américains ont
poussé
l'ex urss aux frontières de la russie
ukraine comprise c'était d'ailleurs ce
que très franchement celui d un brésil
qui a publié en
1997 dans son bouquin le grand échiquier
il a dit sans l'ukraine les russes sont
une puissance moyenne avec l'ukraine ce
sont d une puissance importante donc il
faut les priver de cela alors
effectivement il n'était pas convenu que
chaque fois qu'un état rentrer à
l'intérieur de l'europe ils soient en
même temps membre de l'otan de ce côté
là disons que les russes ont senti
indiscutablement une poussée et le fait
que longtemps les ukrainiens souhaitait
faire partie de l'otan leur paraissait
une ligne rouge qu'il devait pas être
trop franchi voilà ça c'est le point de
vue russe
maintenant est-ce que le meilleur moyen
pour éviter cela c'est la guerre la
question est posée c'est à dire que la
réponse sera qui sera le vainqueur dans
cette affaire où qui aura un compromis à
mon avis un compromis favorable alors
justement compromis est ce que l'issue
pacifique du conflit ça suppose quand
même un accord sur la sécurité en europe
peut-être en hors de l'otan s
aujourd'hui envisageable écoutez l'otan
est intouchable bon c'est déjà une chose
par exemple les romains ils s'inquiètent
pas ils ont raison il se passera rien en
roumanie donc d'une façon générale tout
ça pour l'instant ne concerne que
l'ukraine les ukrainiens est-ce qu'ils
vont avoir les moyens de tenir
suffisamment de temps pour que le dessin
de domination directe ou indirecte
monsieur poutine puisse intervenir ou
est-ce qu'au contraire on va voir un
enlisement
ce qui va créer de sérieux problèmes à
monsieur poutine y compris peut-être
dans le cadre de son pouvoir à moscou
même mais vous pensez qu'il ya un risque
d'engrenage dans l'ex yougoslavie en
bosnie herzégovine dans le caucase on en
parle on en parle c'est à dire qu' il s'
est toujours tentant de dire que bon
dans l'ex yougoslavie il y avait
problème pendant que au caucase rien
n'est réglé alors est ce que ce sera
l'occasion ou pas compte tenu de ce qui
se passe en ukraine et de ce qui se
passera c'est à dire qui va être le
vainqueur que il se passe des choses
ailleurs bon par exemple les chinois qui
jusqu'à présent sont extrêmement discret
s'intéressent beaucoup à ce qui se passe
parce qu'ils se rendent compte que au
cas où il voudrait sans pareil de taïwan
attention l'addition peut être
extrêmement coûteuse donc ça
désintéresse de très près pour l'instant
je crois que c'est circonscrit à
l'ukraine ça allait suffisamment de
travail à monsieur poutine qui pratique
si vous voulez un quitte ou double très
important pour son avenir et que
pensez-vous de la construction d'une
europe de la défense réellement
indépendante du parapluie américain à ce
que d'après vous cela devient
indispensable
pour parler anglais ça s'appelle wishful
thinking
c'est à dire bon ccn
c'est quelque chose hautement
souhaitable mais très franchement
inatteignable il ya soixante ans que
nous faisons l'europe et nous n'avons
pas réussi en matière de sécurité et
moins encore en matière de défense à
avoir une position commune bon monsieur
macron a parfaitement raison on de dire
qu'il le faudrait mais il voit bien
qu'il n'ait pas suivi il vient de
s'entretenir là pendant deux heures
puisque vous en parlez le chef de l'état
avec vladimir poutine quelle est la
nature de ses très longues discussions
deux heures à ce qu'ils y parle d'un
est-ce que l'idh l'éventualité d'un
cessez-le-feu par exemple est évoquée ou
ou est ce que c'est un dialogue de
sourds vous m'en demandez trop un jeu
j'ignore ce qu'ils se sont dit tout ce
que je sais c'est que la position de
monsieur macron c'est que il faut
contenir au maximum le risque de
dérapage que il ne faut pas comment
dirais-je pousser la russie dans ses
derniers retranchements qu'il faut
trouver un accord comment dirais-je
acceptable à peu près pour les deux
parties bref c'est à dire de se
comporter comme un dirigeant européen
responsable enfin il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui s'interrogent sur la
personnalité de vladimir poutine voulant
reconstituer la grande russie certains
disent qu'il n'est pas qui n'a plus le
contact avec la réalité vous qu'en
pensez vous je pense que les gens qui se
livrent à la psychanalyse
sont probablement incompétent comment
est ce qu'on peut dire avec certitude
que monsieur
poutine a perdu le contact avec la
réalité
moi ça me paraît absurde c'est un
excellent tacticien nous allons voir si
en plus d'être tacticien il se révèle un
stratège ou pas merci beaucoup gérard
chaliand pour votre analyse et notre
décryptage sur france24 merci à vous
merci